yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby it's
show business it's no let's get into my
mustache let's get into a lot of stuff
get off my nuts we just need each other
buddy you ready chin let go we started
so oh we started when you said let's get
into the mustache do that yeah no let's
get into my mustache dud get off my nuts
listen I know I'm a Tren not you're not
it's I know I'm the Jared letto of
podcasting it is not your mustache get
off my no I have no interest in copying
you you did though I gave you that idea
subconsciously to oh he looks cool I
went to dinner you know what happened
you came home your wife was like
brendon's mustache went and then next
thing you take a shower you come out of
the shower you have a
mustach you've never had one before till
daddy did it here's the thing hey till
daddy did it you've never had one before
no no no no uh the only reason I did was
this I went to dinner and the young man
had a mustache go I like the mustache he
goes it's November I went right oh right
said that today on the Pod several times
November is when you can grow a mustache
that's what I said I didn't pay those
are my exact words I give you no credit
now do you realize you look like you
touch kids right that's the difference
we'll get to that we'll get to that in a
second you look like you got booked for
molesting children my mother literally
said that my mother said you look like
you should you should be kept away from
the from from middle schools now 20
yards from each school yeah you look
like you touch kids now listen uh I I
said I was looking at my mustache my
facial growth I went very gray around
the cheeks and the chin but black
naturally unlike somebody else black
naturally under the nose I said let's
see what happens if I take it down and
how young I look and I think frankly
that once it comes in it's going to be a
different game around here because I
look like a [__] guy who splits wood
who enforces the law and who [__]
cruises dudes on Christopher Street in
New York City in the 70s all right all
I'm hearing is blah blah blah [__] I
I didn't follow any of that hey it's all
good you ain't the first I want the
first to look at me and go you looked
can I be honest with you hey he looks
good no can I be if you start dressing
like me that's why I draw the line at
your age I draw the line you know what I
want to look like you get rid of that
Tesla and get a cool truck or
something listen I'd be okay with that
listen I know you would I want to look
like a young Don
fry you look like Don Fry's
twink that's exact what you look like
you look like somebody you look like
somebody Don fry unloads his nuts in is
there anybody who looks better with a
mustache and that son of a [__] is
there anybody dude you look like your
sole purpose on this Earth is to take
Don Fry's nuts well I got to be honest
with you you know what your job is
draining Don fr's nuts if I had to be a
bottom and share a prison cell with
somebody it might be Don fry he'd make
you grow out that mustache and take them
loads yeah well now Don fry is a lot
skinnier when he was younger
interesting yeah either way dude take
the loads daddy don't say that okay
you're gonna make that mustache you load
you lift and loads Don fried loads no I
mustaches are when you're a top dude be
cool why don't you be cool not for you
though what not for you you can't drive
bro hey think about your life right
[Music]
now what's so funny hey what's so funny
dude take it easy you drove your your
model 3 Tesla and you have that must
[__] life dude it kicked you in the nuts
and I drove it the speed limit cuz I
worried cuz I don't like to drive to
fast right in the nuts dude dude come on
man sometimes life goes that guy I got
to get back to training hey life went
that guy I got to get back to [__]
training you all my Jiu-Jitsu is on my
back no you know what though bro hey you
know what's great though you know what's
great I take from my boy man you wake up
you look in the mirror sure you look
like you touch kids you have that
mustache there's nothing we can do now
you just look in the mirror and go
good good is nothing do you look like a
French writer who touches kids good you
just got to take it dude you got to
sometimes dude you got to look at your
life and wake up and go here's what I
have don't worry about whether you want
or d i I literally I used that jao thing
today I went good now things went South
on the investment of that Ford Lightning
so oh
no oh no oh no the one I was in yes so
when you buy a car online it doesn't
tell you all the problems and then you
get on the highway and you floor it and
it goes nah good and then it just
doesn't work like it's supposed to and
then you dyo it in front of the most
manly mechanics you know these guys they
have they have the Raptor RS they got
these thousand you know horsepower
diesel in they they're guys I'm like
lightning up there like and it kind of
looks kind of gay compared to their cars
ites look a little bit it's a little
feminine compared to a diesel like2
looks like a a VW Bug got was like I'm
going to go on steroids but it's still a
VW it's like you know it's cute yeah
sure yeah so comp compared to their cars
it's the Paul Walker hitter compared to
their trucks I'm I'm the bottom here
yeah and so they they dyo theirs you
know one's 700 horsepower at the wheels
another's 600 the other's 540 I'm like
oh this is cool get my truck up there
and they're like okay they don't let me
put it on there cuz I look gay and I
have skinny jeans on so they drove my
truck up there hurt my feelings oh boy
so they get the truck on the thing you
you know what Dino at the first time it
went what is Dino at I'm so sry Dino is
how like the the total horsepower to the
wheels okay so it's 20% less usually
20% again these numbers 500 600 700 oh
no oh no
125 hey I went hold on hold on which is
unheard dude it might as well be a Ford
Ranger it's unheard of and people online
like there's no way D 125 I can't
emphasize enough it was 125 went oh
there's something wrong with your dyo
and the guy goes no nope it's your
transmission I go what do you mean I
just bought it he goes yeah but it's 20
years old bud it's your transmission he
goes Florida again get it's not it's
just not there's something wrong with
the transmission oh no what's in the
shop now what did they say has to be
done you've got to get a new
transmission that sold a well you bought
a lemon I'm bought a lemon lemon you had
sold a bill Goods good yeah yeah now now
did the people that sold it to you did
they reach out or they just disappear oh
my team reached out to them gave him a
mouthful yeah went like this he went
good figure it out yeah no but it's it's
not the end of the world it's it's
something we can fix you can trick oh
but we have to switch it out anyways but
here you know me dude I'm a wild card
you're wild card I aim for the stars I
have very high aspirations if it's if
it's available you want it I'll attain
it and I'll get there one way or another
even though I got to start an only fans
account to pay for the mods yeah so the
plan was to get this and swap in a new
Godzilla motor which is like the newest
F Ford motor it's like 7.3 L motor it's
unheard of I'm like we'll just swap it
out sure we'll just take this engine
swap that one in you don't know drucks
Brandon you [__] [__] so it doesn't
work like that so I reached out to a
fell on Instagram who has done this Swap
and I go
how was it man he goes nightmare
nightmare what do you mean he goes oh
dude I don't advise it so many problems
he goes dude you get the engine that's
one cost he goes just to figure it out
and make it work you're look at another
20 grand at least in parts and labor I
went oh oh he goes don't do it man don't
do yeah yeah yeah well I like this guy
throw a Whipple coyote motor in there on
E85 and you'll be pushing 800 horsepower
in that lightweight single cab here's my
plan to for this all this headache where
I shut for the stars and throw the
Godzilla in there I don't need to do
that I can leave the 5.4 lader in there
I know this is all Spanish to you I can
leave the 5.4 liter that it came with
cuz it only has 22,000 mies I'll beef up
the [__] and this thing's going to
throw a bigger blower on there fuel
injectors like the pulley the whole nine
I can get just that stock with about 700
horsepower and that thing's going to rip
it's going to rip here's the problem
yeah you know I I can I say what the
problem is I want right now okay and
they're just they're doing a walk
through they're just going to give it a
quick rund down and tell me exactly how
much it's going to cost for me just a
when I say rip I mean just get it out of
there's a chance they might say now if
you back up a Brinks truck we can do
this but otherwise no not too expensive
no no you're talking if the torque
converter trans you know two three grand
now if I'm hanging out with you guys and
I go you guys trick your trucks out nope
out I'm out no especially that mustache
I go
gay hey guys uh just one gay man asking
here you guys trick your trucks out I
trick my face out those boys eyes around
at 805 diesel they'll Stone you for that
man right oh yeah they'll Stone you I
can't trick my I tricked my face D dude
there's guys then there's diesel guys
yeah men I'm not talking about the
diesel guys you meet on West Hollywood
I'm talking diesel engine about guys
that work on the engin grease on their
fingers cuz remember Diesel's for
workers that's like the F250s the
Cummings the big boys the big boys
diesel yeah the ram 2500s that they're
using them for work
I'm not one of those guys not one of
those no and if I'm not
there if I if daddy's not there what
compared to you what do you mean oh you
know what you're doing you're putting a
[__] thong on with that mustache and
sudsing up the wheels while we watch you
I don't want to S I have to arch my back
dude you you know what you do for my
truck you put the Twizzlers in the
[__] glove box and then get
out no no make sure my Twizzlers are not
stale and then get the [__] out I got to
stock you up yeah twizz Daddy needs
Twizzlers and big gulps then get out big
gos too yeah dude so I got to carry a
big go and just think yeah aong where do
you want these a thong stupid mustache
what the f and I got to sud your wheels
up too oh yeah that's your only job
suding my wheels and taking Don fry done
what do I do take Don Fry's load and
then and then shut up and get the [__]
out of there [__] out of 805 diesel
where am I supposed to go I don't give a
[__] just get the [__] out charge your
stupid soy boy car up and get the road
well what if I want to get into the
truck game Jack yeah jump in the back of
the bed and get that mouth ready for the
boys oh my God yeah thank you s so
disrespectful you're a lot lizard to us
bud I don't want to be dude I'm feminine
around these 805 boys I'm a person right
me I'm just a h I can [__] you whenever
I want that's what's
crazy dude I'm closer to Hulk Hogan than
you are dude dude come on man be cool no
bro be cool I want to be part of the
grou things are different now hey guys
what you all doing tricking your trucks
out hey guys hey anybody know where I
can sup my truck up oh gross hey guys
I'm looking for a starter truck man what
kind of rims should I get I want to know
like I want to hey guys you guys you got
anybody here running a
Hemi getting better myad getting better
y'all running a Hemi man some carburetor
or fuel injection not manad right okay I
got watch this watch this you'll love
this yep used to run run a a Ford Bronco
71 had a windsor 350 in there and uh he
sniff like that trying to be Mao trying
to be maybe I've been doing a little
blow cuz it dulls the pain got a little
I got a little blow around my mud
whistle nickname around the shop your
nickname around the shop what's my
nickname Grease
Monkey well I've heard Grease Monkey it
just means I work with my hands yeah you
grease monkey what do you mean you
grease more than my hands up you the
grease [__] the shop you don't take a
big old bring out the grease [__] you
don't take a big slap of the grease [__]
slap it on the get over here get over s
them Wheels I got I got a Le Wheels yeah
bro man do I live in a box whatever God
this is gay as [__] this is strongly gay
the crates at the big engine's coming
that's where you
live get get over here get over here you
throw a little cereal in there little
hard candy and cereal s some Wheels boy
can I get some water no dude you spray
me down with a hose I give you a sip on
my big gol there you a little [__] you
suck it in [__] suck it in it's enough
enough enough I said enough God damn
it stupid ass grease
g just just
thirsty I'm tired my knees have bruises
on them from Suds and wheels no you have
a ball in your mouth dude you're not
talking wow you have a ball your mouth
that's sponsored by some company we sold
out
to ball and gag oh God yeah I can't wait
to get rid of this mustache I should say
I can't wait till my the rest of my face
grows in I tried it my daughter goes
like this she goes I can't I took her to
dinner she goes oh my God too much yeah
you just look like such a molest
yeah
yeah yeah I got that going for me um at
least she can control your facial hair
yeah you know except top you God your
Barber well it's a problem it's getting
worse and worse oh it's not going to get
better yeah I could get a hair
transplant um turkeyed out turkey
reached out they yeah dude do it look at
Don Cerrone full-blown set of ha looks
like he's part of [__] Donald went on
the old sauce and everything Donald's
like get talk to me sauce isn't for you
but the let let me see his hair go go to
the one below that holy [__] holy [__]
look at that one in the ice Tu bro he
looks like fantastic the the muscular
Beetle can't do that is he in a cold
bath yeah but look at this full-blown
that could be you nuts that Don has that
much hair you just got to go to I think
he looked great with a shaved head so I
he looks so much better now I think he
sh head that's cuz you have no hair but
if you did that that's a lot of hair you
know what though can I be honest with
I don't have the kind of hair that does
that I have very what you're doing it's
called self sabotage cuz you're scared
to make the trip good hair and see what
life offers you it's good hair can I see
more hair on him let's
see he usually wears hats right so
that's why it's tough he looks like he's
enjoying hear cowboy hats all the time
they might that one with the yeah look
at it's in his eyes bro and but he had
no hair on this area zero they implanted
there and it grew yeah and fullard take
it from the back of your head full
beard he got a good beard mhm he's young
he's still what is he 40 at the most
maybe he has to be right around my age
he's two he said he was like 200
something pounds I mean but look at that
look at his hair dude he he has to wave
it now yeah it's good hair that could be
you just go to Turkey and they they're
offering to do it they gave Donald a
first round that's what they said to me
trip I just got to I just got to promote
mhm I do it dude you know how many
freaking people would sign up for that
if they saved your hair Cowboy's younger
so the people like do a good job you
dude what but that this would be my
second hair transplant but last time you
did in the '90s
yeah different game technology popping
now dadd it is right look man sometimes
you got to go cold turkey on oh it's so
tough to stop a bad habit but what if we
just take the bad of the Habit can you
do that yeah how about fume what spell
Fu M okay it's a different way of doing
things okay they look at the problem
different dude not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of the crazy
uncomfortable changes of going cold
turkey you just remove the bad from The
Habit we're talking about fume it uses
flavored Air instead of vapor in of
natural uses delicious flavors okay it's
it's habit it's habit free all right
dude they got this new soloa solo Sola
no oh yeah oh it's delicious dude it's
premium Walnut Carl all right it is
fantastic start the holidays off right
with good habit by going to trif
nume.com that's TR R yfu m.com fighter
and getting the journey pack today fume
is giving you guys 20% off until
December 1st when you use the code
fighter to help make starting the good
habit that much easier tryf nume.com
fighter look diversify your portfolio
dude all I do is collect gold coins and
silver like Scrooge McDuck bro well
precious medals gold seem seems to hold
its value at least if human history is a
guide it's not like I got this gold what
am I going to do with it ah throw it
away it's worth nothing where do I get
it where do I get it gold Co okay it's
helped thousands of people place over
$2.5 billion in gold and silver are they
trusted though rated A Plus by the
Better Business Bureau they've earned
over 5,000 f-star reviews and they are
seven time Inc 5,000 winner and that's
just mentioning a few of the ACC
accomplishments so right now for the
fighter and kid listeners they are
offering up to1 ,000 in bonus Silvers
while supplies last go to Gold code.com
fighter tolearn more all right diversify
your portfolio heads your bets go to
Gold code.com fighter G D code.com
fighter I should talk that'd be sick
dude yeah you think or would it be sad
no sad is what it is right
now so you're a lady what do you think
should I do it I mean I think or does it
matter why would you ask a girl she
don't want to hurt your I care about
girls opinions no I'm I'm your friend
fix your [__] hair it's bringing my
Daya shave it shave it everybody likes a
bald dude oh bad idea why shave head
with that mustache I like bald dudes
we'll get rid must we'll get rid of the
mustache is that you freezing up dude
you look like Jimmy Burke you know you
know a lot of people I think as you get
older you know what I heard uh did you
hear that that X Freeman Elon Musk uh
interview no I missed that one did it
sound like two robots no uh Elon Musk
said a lot of people think they want to
be me but I don't think they do no heavy
lies the crown and he said I want his
bank account yeah but he said something
really wild he goes my brain's a storm
he can't shut off it's a it's a curse
yeah but in order to get to his level it
has to like he's working on such a
different wavelength that anybody else
is on the earth he can't turn it off so
it's a curse man it's just like I
thought it was interesting like a lot
you you always want something you don't
have you always want to kind of you can
do this and maybe things and you want a
mustache you got it it's a well I'm much
happier with this mustache but it's a
it's a it's all a trap but I was just
thinking I was like [__] I was
watching him I was like you have all the
money in the world you're such a leader
in industry and such you think he was
going to say he's your brain storm you
know he said how you doing Alex said how
you doing he said I'm all right
considering you know in the grand scheme
of things I suppose I'm all right and I
went damn bro think about anybody at a
high level like even if you're not high
level just daily [__] that da [__] daily
[__] as as you get more visible more
powerful more [__] hen more [__] is is
laid at your play plus Elon took on this
huge project with X with you know the
Born company all that stuff trying to
get to Mars and then with he talked
about on uh Rogan with Tesla like the
production it's a nightmare dude
like yeah the fires he has to solve
every day now he's asked for it and he's
at that level and he's the perfect guy
for the job but he doesn't wake up and
like I'm a billionaire give me my juice
and everything's you know Dand lines and
mustaches no in his uh in his biography
I guess it was like he creates these
insane situations but then walks right
through him you know and in some ways
it's like people get addicted to well
it's what he is he's just he just he's
just Relentless about ideas people told
him it would never ideas and people yeah
exactly ideas and also like that he's
the type of dude he's a leader that we
need in this world not politically just
what he's doing you need people that
look at the toughest problem go and run
towards it well everyone else is just
waiting for him to fa well everybody
else is going I hope he fails you can't
do it all those people don't count
they're all cheap yeah but the leaders
they're not sheep everyone's rooting for
anyone who's doing anything in life is
rooting for that guy whether your left
or right you're I couldn't agree more
the minute I see somebody criticizing
Elon I'm like oh boy you got to get your
life together you're you're you're
rooting against that guy who C that many
jobs and you know okay all right yeah it
was really interesting though I was just
like man like that that that was when he
said my brain's a storm I felt bad for
the guy I kind of had comp I was like
yeah money doesn't solve those problems
it's like my my one buddy who's you know
done done crazy crazy well in business
too and he said uh I was talking to me
he goes [__] I put out one fire and
then another fire comes up it's like I
can't it's like my life is putting fires
out all the time you don't get to that
level without putting out fires I was
like this is what it is you're putting
out fires it's just different their bank
accounts are different their fires are
different yeah yep pretty wild and
that's why you grow a mustache and I
will say I look a lot younger I think
because it's
dark naturally this this is what's left
of my youth where this is the part that
stayed dark everything else went correct
has anybody listened to The Rock Dwayne
The Rock Johnson on Rogan no how you
what do you think is I haven't listened
to it I I just got my car to shoot some
stuff with uh Casey and it popped up on
my screen I'm like holy [__] he had the
rock on Jelly Roll Just canceled on
us I love the I I'm really looking
forward to listening to that it's
definitely a good listen I just saw like
the first 30 minutes they they had a big
workout with like uh Tony henchcliffe
and uh uh Shane Gillis they just worked
out talked was the rock like hey [__]
get my
weights like think how weak like think
how weak those guys are compared to the
Rock and Rogan's strong as [__] too but
compared to the
Rock he probably like hey can you spot
me what do you guys doing here that's a
big strong can everybody spot me Suds
the wheel I used to watch him Suds the
wheel he used to be at golds in Venice I
used to watch him work out probably 15
years ago they had to put up a sign no
when I was when I first moved to LA he
was there all the time they to put a
sign up don't ask the rock questions or
take pictures cuz he couldn't work out
it's ex no way they put signs up around
the gym don't ask the rock for for
pictures or questions he was there all
the time every time I'd be there well
big that was when he was like just a
beefy like yet just starting this
entertain
yeah he was big he was before he got
really even now he's like different big
but he's big played football with Warren
Sapp uh uh Miami yeah yeah was he
starter he said really he said he
realized he was not going to be a pro I
think when he got hit by Warren Sap or
he something like that he was like I got
I saw the guys that were going to the
pros and and I was like his team was
good too yeah yeah not a starter played
all four years I think so yeah that's
significant on Miami that's a big deal
if he played but I know he's rotating in
but Warren Sap they played the same
position oh
gotcha
yeah but he must have been good to get a
scholarship from wherever he was to yeah
yeah I say he you know he's a winner in
general he's put out fires too man 100%
100% you're always putting out fires um
what else is going on so your truck had
a little little little malfunction are
you only driving your truck now or do
you drive your car do you do you are you
no I still drive the car I just you know
yeah I still drive the the other car but
no that dude I've had you know this I've
been a car guy for hot I've had
everything but now you're an American
Car Guy dude you you you name it for
Exotics your boys had it I've driven
them all I've never driven a better
vehicle than that TRX that Ram TRX not
close what do you mean it it's just
everything the power the way it feels
the interior is dope it's it's so
comfortable
great fast as all get out wow really the
best out of all the Porsches and
everything Ferraris everything I'm done
with them done with it sold all of them
done with it damn done with it why it's
just to have too much work a goddamn
American you piece of [__] oh you're an
American yeah bro dude yeah bro I want
two American flags
just what the [__] bro Trump 2024 no
take it easy
man take it you seen those trucks oh
yeah you're like oh my God that guy's
intense oh my God he cut you off all
have a good day you did you know that
guy don't take no [__] my wife has a um
a summer house in Delaware and you go
there in the summer and that's where
Biden's from but but let me tell you
when you see these these boats pull up
you got a lot of them Trump boats that
pull up with just the the flags and
just Trump you know just it's
unbelievable man that fan base like the
hardcore Trump fan base is int that's my
demo but even uh chin you were watching
the UFC at a bar and chintsa when they
showed Trump the the crowd at the bar
nuts but the UFC audience of course
that's his demo like me it's crazy but
Jim was at where you at Silver Lake no
no it's uh Korea Town it's actually in
Korea Town it's called beer garden well
you know Asians and Latin Latin the
Latin population is trending Republican
they're they're going away from this
woke stuff I don't know if you know this
but Miss Universe been around forever
Trump bought Mr Universe well Trump
bought it in '95 own till 2006 uh well
it it got bought by a Thai uh lady boy
uh a woman who a man who became a woman
bought by by this person and and so the
two runner-ups so the two runner-ups
this year are men who are you know but
they're trans women and uh well they
just file for bankruptcy oh really
yeah you mean the mass audience is into
it they couldn't make their their their
dividend payment they they just filed
for bankruptcy so Miss Universe because
people were like hey wait a minute men
are taking over this space that women
were in and now you're going to nominate
two men women's rights you have dudes
winning the contest like wow they said
when Trump own let me get this straight
men are the best best swimmer best
female swimmers in the world they're the
prettiest women in the world it just men
seem to dominate every time they step in
they they said when Trump own Mrs
Universe he come The Green Room like
what's up [__] well that's why hey
man we're getting ready for an event
he's like there pictures of that I mean
this why he owned it I oh oh the the
[__] biller B Mrs univers you don't
think he's hanging out in the changing
rooms come on you guys getting changed
why do you think he bought it want me to
hold your water or yeah they say you go
in the groom like let me get that zipper
for you good luck [__] they're all
hey man all right you guys all look
great you look great I'm going to do I'm
going to do I'm going to look at all
your costumes make sure everything is on
the up and up didn't said when he met
him he goes you're doing great he's like
I'm just here man what you're doing
great you're doing great yep that's
right you're doing great yeah he's uh
he's a colorful he's interesting
character he is the orange Club the
American a lot of Americans are using to
bash the ruling Elite let's put put it
that way mhm MH I watched that new movie
on Netflix that uh the killer yes did
you watch it I did I got sucked in and
then it's because because that director
I love did did Fight Club he's done a
bunch of movies that I absolutely love
Yeah David uh Fincher is itch yeah
excellent director amazing excellent
director amazing one one of my favorites
this movie is a little slow a little
slow it's supposed to be on a serial
killer um I'm sorry a a hitman hired
Hitman yeah he the it's the guy from 300
is it fast Bender no Michael Fender
Michael fast Bender he doesn't talk no
supposed to have a crazy piece on him by
the way I knew that from day one dude
he's got a duck on
him in that movie what is that movie I
mean
aick no 300 yeah bring up Michael fast
Bender's thei he's going to pop up the
bring it up tin bring it up bro but uh
did you see twin Flames that documentary
no look lame oh boy just put penis or
dick or what do you want to do I don't
know okay can't you D it put penis let's
see what comes up yeah cuz it was like
the guy from uh Madmen that just has a
[__] tank on him madman John Ham yes
John Ham thre his khakis bro that thing
is like juicy it's juicy there you go oh
that thing is long no no that's not
that's not that's no that's him dud dick
fake no it's a fake dick from uh that's
a fake dick from the move uh from the
show uh you know no I was a body double
on that I was a body no that that's
literally a fake dick that's gross
that's fast Bender's dick that's long
and thin yeah he's got a he's got a
piece yeah that Twizzler dick long and
thin yeah he's got a I think that's him
I don't know if it is either way the
rumor is he has a [__] P he's got a
he's got a hammer on him he has a super
soaker down there the picture won't even
go that far that's how big it is dude he
skinny and he's got a long un Neary the
skinny guys always have the big is that
it did you recognize this I don't
know didn't see it just heard it no no
far as he's got to trim his Bush he's a
bush there but that thing's long man
yeah he's got I'm it's a respectable
piece you got him in the ball ball
Department I do I got him in I might
have him in the T no not fast Bender I
think I'm all right I think I'm right
there no you're doing well you're you're
about an inch shy Bud an in shy listen
if this is a vertical jump he's at 40
you're about 38 there's there a video
yep there there's a whole trend on
Instagram I don't know if you've seen it
but of guys doing jumping jacks or
whatever it is show in in in shorts uh
very loose shorts with with half a
chubby oh yeah my algorithm doesn't show
me that cuz I'm not gay okay here's the
problem you got that mustache sent it to
my wife so it came up on my feed cuz I'm
a gay man sent it to my wife and said
something to the effect of I just
accused her of being you know into it
into it yeah and uh well don't do that
because when you do that what happens is
they'll send you all the guys doing that
oh they go oh did you like that were you
going to love this and you get a ton of
that well then I sent
another mine's all trucks yours alls I
sent her another one that's a really big
mistake because then in my feed I got a
and I'm on the plane I'm going through
my my thing and I get a guy in a thong
and he's on his elbows with his huge
hairy ass in the air and I I went I
couldn't I was like oh Jesus like you
have to just [__] scroll through cuz
the guy behind you you're S no if you're
sitting next me I'm R your oh my God I
know I was no yeah look how you doing
like how don't put a guy with a thong
with his ass in the air man so hairy and
there are people who get behind that and
go there it is yeah teach their own yep
what do you got Jen current events teach
teach his own to each his own s this one
okay uh Aaron Rogers you know last game
was not out on the field throwing balls
but he says he's coming back my boy mid
December he's right up here wait wait
wait how here doing rehab you tell me
how it's right up here doing rehab wow
he's in West Hills that's impressive
though right yeah hell yeah but with
modern science all that stuff damn
IAA sure that's nsos nsos I mean I've
never heard of that I thought that 39
years old you got a torn Achilles I mean
no I don't think he's going be moving
around like a young spring chicken but
he can at least throw that pig skin I
thought that was a year at least in
recover that's what they thought but
they don't know Aaron
roders I don't know you know um you
suspect a little suspect it's an
Achilles what's the suspect you you know
you don't think he TOS Achilles I don't
know if it was as big of a tear as
they're saying it was definitely
probably wasn't oh no complete tear I
know for a fact it was a complete
complete tear dude I had some coffee and
I put milk too much coffee man too much
coffee I don't feel great well you know
what you know all I'm drink is Black
Coffee dude you got to get some omega-7
fatty acids in your body you got to get
the kind of fatty acids that your body
craves that makes you healthier I'm
talking about Macadamia milk I'm talking
about House of macadamia you get the
best macadamia nuts on the planet you
want chocolate covered you want white
chocolate covered you want raspberry
covered I got it all for you but if you
tell me you're going give me a free
gallon of macadamia milk I'm going to
freak out well you're about to well you
should freak out right now go ahead and
freak out cuz I'm going to give you a
free gallon of nutmilk okay 100% pure
Macadamia has no added sugars oil
stabilizers preservatives other nut
milks contain it's environmentally
friendly you get a free gallon of
macadamia milk when you visit houseof
macademia
docomo to your cart with any products
and use code TF a and get healthier and
in many ways get get skinnier people
that study longevity that want to live a
lot longer apparently eat up to two
handfuls of macadamias a day look at us
house academia.com
TFA
delicious um I want to talk to you guys
about fieldcraft survival my buddy Mike
Clover who was a
greenber 18 years in the military just
did a podcast with him survival pack for
my TRX dude I got to I know for your
favorite car right for my truck car he
sent me one and I it went to a different
um it went to a different it went to
somebody address what do you mean not
for me I want some survival well one of
the things he found is like most people
are just not ready you think that
nothing's going to happen to you and
then when it happens you sink to the
level of your training and you have
nothing he's got the fieldcraft survival
digital app contains long form
educational content for all things
preparedness you got tactical
self-defense Jiu-Jitsu medical survival
Bushcraft family preparedness disaster
preparedness and a lot more from
beginners to Advanced
beginners that's right because we're
Advanced and you got each topic is it's
it's a structured Master Class style
format nobody he's so articulate and
good at at conveying information and you
can really learn whatever skill set is
necessary to become more prepared so you
can become you his philosophy is you are
your first responder is people think
helicopter's going to land in my
backyard ready to go you got to be ready
so um but can you give us a deal I'll
give you how about this two offers so go
to fieldcraft survival.com
fighter that's fieldcraft survival.com
Fighter um and uh this app and this
information could very well save your
life be prepared use the code fighter 30
that's fighter 30 to get 30 days free or
for 35% off your annual subscription you
go to fighter 35 that's promo code
fighter 35 yep my created by Mike Clover
spent 18 years in the military with in a
lot of combat experience so uh if
anybody knows about survival and
preparedness it's Mike lover get on the
train all right next one sonas little
NFL heavy today guys so Patrick Mahomes
went on Eli and his brother's podcast
and said he's got a pair of Lucky
underwear that he washes sometimes yeah
I I wore the same underwear when I
fought every fight superstitious but I
would clean them you was them right I
wash them after fight go months without
washing them if they're on a streak even
if you don't have [__] stre speaking
speaking of stre even even if you don't
have [__] stains out the back which is
very tough to do as a grown man but even
if you don't it's just just that hot
Carriage under there it just stinks over
time man it gets ripe dude your [__]
you have to keep your keep your whistle
clean you could eat off my whistle it's
always you wish boy
just
saying yeah not was him's a little weird
wearing the same ones is unheard of but
not was him's strange it's not super
cool yeah I wore the same ones every
fight all righty this one
here yeah you want to do this one all
right um oh my God yeah dude famous Tik
tocker over here went and got his
eyeballs tattooed black anything for the
clicks right guys you know how bad that
would hurt oh oh I mean of course he did
I see I thought it was the girls in the
Tik Tok video oh this guy was going to
do it whether he Tik Tok famous or not
yeah that guys I mean oh my gosh yeah
things aren't going guys do got in
prison apparently it's super dangerous
cuz you know obviously your eyes not
made to take ink pigment so when you do
it people go blind from it it's super
danger one girl it's tough to find a
tattoo AR to do it cuz the liability he
probably did it himself I think
something no it cost him 10 grand it
said yeah something to find somebody to
do it it's very challenging so I guess
what is it when people have face tattoos
there's it's like almost guaranteed they
suffer from a
thousand issues depression is that
science a thousand it's like so many
like well post Malone talked about he
got face stattoos he hates his face yeah
it's very sad that's tough though that
that's really tough that's a crazy Chris
got a neck tattoo cuz he hates a skinny
neck that's a that's a mask you know
that's a mask mask that that what he's
wearing he's literally wearing a mask I
think some people get face tattoos cuz
like the cool thing to do right now and
they don't have mental issues I think
some people like that guy's entire face
and eyeballs are covered that's a
different he he's yeah that's tough yeah
yeah I I remember I I was doing onad TV
1996 the first time I ever saw somebody
with tattoos on their face and on their
whole body in 96 so this guy yeah this
guy showed up and he had we were doing a
sketch with him and he had um balls
little round balls BS in his skin oh
yeah yeah and he T and he told me that
he had pierced his testicles not the
skin but his actual testicle and and uh
that's not healthy yeah and he said um
you go somewhere the pain is so bad that
I went somewhere that I didn't think
existed like I he went to a different
dimension I was like I'm sure dude but
he was obviously got off on the pain he
got off on it I never forgot that yeah I
don't get down with that piercing your
nuts D even if you had a tattoo below
your bicep like my grandpa had it when
he was in the in the Marines my uncle
had it like D full sleeves yeah like in
the 50s 60s 7s dude you're a real wild
cat wild cat or your Hell's Angel yes I
mean the tattoos were always like even
my growing up I'm old enough to remember
in when I was in high school if you saw
a tattoo it was like oh [__] even when I
was growing up yeah you're like oh that
kid's trouble yeah 100% and neck tattoos
I said I sat next to the the lead singer
of social distortion on a plane and he
had a tattoo I think of a squirrel I
mean of a sparrow and I was like oh [__]
that's that guy with the neck tattoo it
was like a big deal nobody had neck neck
tattoo is still a little alarming for me
I love him I'd want one but you you got
to be really set financially to do that
space yeah that guy he's a good guy yeah
but he's a lead singer of a band you bet
your sweet ass has a neck tude but he
got it way
early is that right there yeah it's a
pan like I said it was a sparrow it was
a sparrow
it's not what it look like is there
another tattoo on his there's there's a
bunch you never sat next to him D he no
I did I promise you think he was just
the guy you assumed was in a band no no
no I sat next because I do the same no
no I I do the same uh there you're right
BR on the right side got bird there you
go baby some kind of bird there it is
how fun I would love a neck tattoo
that's when you know I'm good
financially when I have a neck tattoo
yeah that's it there it is yeah that's
exactly what he looked like when I sat
next to him he was singing it like that
he was seeing it just like that plan
yeah With Arms Wide Open that's not his
song that's Creed don't ever say that
again what song does he sing he had they
have a really famous song China the
Chinese chicken like take away take away
that one song what song ball and chain
I'm not going to sing it relax ball and
chain yeah how's it go I'm not saying
are you familiar with him Chen social D
yeah come on guys social what's her most
famous song we can edit this out if you
guys want yeah please give it to me then
I'll sing it for
everybody
So Hot Topic
tired all right Chim we got it is ball
take
away Bo I like are they still performing
yeah they still tour I think I'm bet you
haven't seen them on tour you go they'll
tour with a bunch of people yeah they
all partner up and like you know it's
tough if you like some 41 you're like
Papa Roach I'm like I guess you come out
and you sing the same roach is on tour
you bet you're sweet ass they are
they're doing great they're crushing it
are they yeah cut my life into pieces
and there's just 50-year-olds like yeah
oh cut my life in 50 yeah yeah it's all
in memory that's what that's what a lot
of uh Taylor Swift a lot of the older
women that were there they were all
singing together remember this it's like
all
right T been famous forever yeah now
they're 30 she came with an album with
their old songs that was still number
one God she has a super DED like
dedicated fan base and they're enormous
and you're and you're one of them
Playboy you and I talk about the road
right and um I remember she had been I
met her and she had been on the road for
365 days like she was on the road
literally all over the world and I would
go crazy I couldn't do it I could on a
private jet best hotels in the world I
don't think I well she doesn't have a
family though if you're single when dude
I'd be private jet best restaurants how
much should I make tonight Ching tits
out yeah she's going to make a killing
when this Travis Kelce thing blows over
that's her next album right there for
sure Heartbreak Hotel baby he can't dump
her though oh he will everyone will hate
him he's going to cheat no by Everyone
by everyone it's the swifties Travis
Kelce doesn't give a [__] this is so
funny Travis Kelce was plenty famous
before any of swifties known him and
will remain famous among people that
actually pay his bills the swifties
ain't paying his bills no maybe they are
now but he he'll get a lot of hate for
sure but he don't have you seen that
trend on on where the girls the girls
[__] with their husbands and they go did
you see this football player I'm so
happy for him he's now famous and every
guy's like you got to stop talking right
now you mean the guy who's got two Super
Bowl rings you got to stop talking yeah
some regard is the best tight end in the
NFL what do you think what do you mean
dude teror is all right what's that I
think Taylor Swift is all right no no no
Travis Kelce as far as being the best
tight end he's great yeah
phenomenal man the Chiefs are what um
seven- two yeah they're all
right they're all right Kim Kardashian
is gq's Man of the Year wait real quick
did I tell you guys the story of me
getting like one of Taylor Swift's very
first CDs no no please tell us so uh her
first hit was it's called Tim mcra Tim
mcra is my favorite you know country
music artist of all time so when Taylor
Swift came out she made a song called
Tim mcra and she said for like the first
what 50 whatever or 100 I don't know
what it was she's going to autograph the
CD I have that autographed CD somewhere
at my parents house somewhere I don't
know where it's out but it's got to be
worth a ton right now yeah I wonder how
much it's worth look it up autograph
Taylor Swift first her first CD yeah
yeah or did you just put yeah is it Tim
mcgr album no uh was a single no no it
was at her actual CD but Tim MRA was her
her main single dude I bet you get 30 40
bucks for that man
I'm not going to look it up that dude no
I bet I bet you 200 bucks way more
autograph I don't know those swifties
are wild I'm not I'm listen they
probably already have autog though
autograph Taylor Swift CD hold on first
edition yeah
first well there's a signed
one oh oh 2,000 that's good that that's
the actual cover damn you have that two
grand daddy let's sell that thing get a
new computer damn no you got us a new
computer so thank you yeah appreciate
that that's money I could have used for
T I thought it' be way worth way more so
let me see this you thought two grand
I'm so I can't believe it's two grand
that's hell that's [__] her first
like her first CD autographed by her all
right um this one's a little weird guys
so gq's man of the year is Kim
Kardashian what do you guys thoughts on
that I love Kim it doesn't make sense
man of the year though yeah appar
there's not a lot of dudes doing well no
it's all part of this gender uh
reconfiguring see you can say you're a
woman as long as you uh were aess so
you've reduced holy [__] it says other
honores include Travis Scott he killed a
guy many yeah that's crazy he's coming
back dear Hamlin too like what are we
talking about well come on Demar Hamlin
deserves it man died on the field yeah
but that not an accomplishment he came
back I don't care Man of the Year dude
he died on the field that's not an
accomplishment that that's an
unfortunate thing and he's lucky he's
alive it's not an accomplishment you
don't give somebody man of the year
because they [__] died on the field
oh you're tough bro and and and I don't
guess who's not working man of the year
why album sales oh okay I don't know so
it's all reduced to a number how is Elon
not Man of the Year F we talking about B
Twitter yeah what are we talking about
this is where this is where our culture
and woke ideology or whatever you want
to call it just [__] it's like you guys
are just lying you're lying but I also
take it down a notch I think too I think
uh they made Kim Man of the Year cuz
skims is in the NBA now so you and the
NFL technically with Botha but yeah but
they sponsored the NBA the Brooklyn Nets
right no the NBA oh the whole thing yes
she did a whole deal with the NBA so
that's all they're trying to Market I'm
sure it's a whole marketing campaign for
her that's all that is I don't think
it's one of those woke things I think
it's trying to get traction with their
skims and NBA thing right that's fine
see Kim Kardashian skims now the
official underwear of the NBA and WNBA
well why not make her the women of the
year and say promote WNBA why would you
make no gives a [__] I'll answer that no
because it's got to be yeah it's it's
I'll take it from here just nobody
watches the W WNBA that's why yeah why
wouldn't you make Kim Kardashian the
woman of the year if she's that big a
businesswoman and she's got this she
crushing it right she's a woman but and
that photo shoot was cool she did it
like her dad cuz Dad was that big time
lawyer but the idea is to say look
there's no difference between men and
women we can interchange them anytime we
want that's really what it is there's no
category Cheetos like a man only many
Cheetos dude this thing's sexist who's
Jacob
elordi see no one knows she's very
pretty I really she's very she's
gorgeous yeah gorgeous she she looks how
old is she she looks fantastic she's 45
oh he's great he's in Euphoria they they
offered him the Superman rooll he's like
I don't like those movies I'm out
they're like we get that but you're
basically broke from
[Music]
Euphoria what else you got J all
right what's up guys if you're like me
using the white nickam pouches all the
time I mean when you see me if you watch
anything I do I use on podcast I'm on
stage when I'm working out when I'm at
home I'm constantly using those nicotine
pouches then I found black Buffalo my
favorite they're made right here in the
the US OFA there's no tobacco leaf or
stem again made in the USA it's made of
edible Green Leaf nothing you would to
eat in a salad it's black Buffalo they
have all the great flavors mint
Wintergreen straight is my personal
favorite so if you're 21 or older and
use nicotine or tobacco check out black
Buffalo it's black buffalo.com
take away take away um I don't know if
you guys watched the Warriors game last
night but Draymond Green is being
Draymond Green again rear naked choke
mhm like What's Happening Here let me
see uh there's one that we I think that
we can play this one
yeah he's just defending my boy Klay
Thompson come on
dude he's not he's not applying any joke
hold now to be fair uh Rudy Gober is uh
French so he's not going to fight
back he's like
man we we we
[Music]
yeah
but
right okay but last year he stepped on a
guy remember that on someone's chest
dude this is '90s basketball that's what
we want he also he only gets ejected he
only gets ejected if Steph's not
playing he's like I don't want to play
if Steph's not here and he gets ejected
but he's defending Klay Thompson who's
my favorite so I'll take it I mean clay
Jersey got ripped Clay's My Boy Love
Clay love his dad great family but I
mean it's a little excessive that's like
a rear niked choke a little bit it's
good for society you get in trouble for
that right who getss spend 3 to 10 games
is that true yeah really three to 10
damn yeah all right so Georgie just saw
this pop up today Francis R number 10 in
the world I sent this to the it was like
490th 490th
earlier if you're a Francis fan this is
why this is good if he's ranked whatever
490 in the world you're not going to get
the big dogs to take the fights now he's
10 now you can get some big fights
talking about uh what's it chora he's
supposed to fight chur next who [__]
who's fought uh who's fought Fury Three
Times U he lost he's lost all three but
he's got knocked out twice by Fury but
now chur is going to take the fight with
Francis which is a big fight not a huge
name fight but still chur is ranked the
top 10 why wouldn't they have him fight
someone like Anthony Joshua Joshua
doesn't want the fight he doesn't want
fight that's the problem can't get the
cuz this is where [__] Francis with
negotiating the pay-per-view numbers
came out awful so now the juice isn't
worth the squeeze because now it comes
out Francis can box so it's not going to
be a walk in the park so they're like
hold up a it's going to be a tougher
fight so there's no upside for me B
people aren't actually watching [__]
that so they they move on like Anthony
Joshua is going to fight Joseph Parker
next which is a great fight yeah I
thought they fought haven't they fought
before Joshua Parker I think they did
I'll look at they were right in each
other's Grill too that that's that was
interesting but Francis should get a big
fight being ranked 10 now he can get
some big fights and that's all we care
about because if you care about Francis
it's
good yeah they fought in 2018
yeah uh where's Deontay Wilder and all
this oh Deontay Wilder I he's fighting
um was it Andy re or not happening I
don't know that was floating
around oh no uh Joseph Parker's fighting
Deontay Wilder my bad I confused Anthony
Joshua and uh Deontay Wilder it's Wilder
that would be interesting yeah it's
Wilder very yeah yeah that's gonna be
good um
why separ what's next for Joshua we
don't know
yet but it's supposed to be wilder vers
Joseph Parker yeah you know Parker was
the first guest ever on food truck
Diaries was he I remember first in Vegas
tried feeding him a fish he wouldn't eat
it such D we got uh uh the stamp Tech
Spar stamp faex yeah but Deontay Wilder
was also one of the biggest of all time
yeah on Big B breakdown one of the first
interviews he did with us yeah is there
any talk of our of Bud uh Crawford
fighting him and ear or next yeah
they're GNA fight the rematch happen
again
yeah take away take away damn uh what
dude should we do this one do we kind of
touch on this is a sad one no it's not
sad it's just like oh Will Smith playing
booty games so apparently there's rumors
that uh they're saying that that Will
Smith was a was a bottom with
Dwayne what's the guy from uh Above the
Rim Dwayne Martin yeah he was in above
the you know him from Above the Rim very
famous actor
according to this like assistant to Will
Smith he walked in the green room and
the guy from Above the Rim was balls
deep in Will Smith now Will Smith is
threatened to sue himation that's what
uh Jada said
but wait Jada exposed him no no no she's
saying my Su homeboy who came out and
said Will's gay look how can you go back
to that how can you prove it though
listen to what he says uh in an
interview with Tasha K that gained wi
attention Bal detailed the alleged
incident saying I the door to Dwayne's
resing room and that's when I see Dwayne
having anal sex with will there was a
couch and Will was bent over the couch
and Dwayne was standing up killing him
murdering him it was murder in there
it's like bro hey dude take it down or
not I know it's like I know you're gay
yeah he said murdering that ass yeah I
don't think so he was murdering that ass
sh sh it was hot I mean he bad
yeah I don't know yeah whatever it's
rumors but yeah here's my thing imagine
if Will's actually not gay he's like
what the [__] man yeah he would be by
then right which that's a gay face I'll
be honest with you he's making he's
making it he's like yeah right there I'm
just saying that he's making a bit of a
gay face let's be honest not will but
the other guy oh I mean will can't catch
a break right now I know I'm a fan too
man yeah I am too we can't slap at the
Oscars and not catch he no and I think
it really did I think he he really has
[__] with him and and it should in a
way was Will Smith's best friend Jesus
Christ tells all best friend a 40 years
you hate to see it Jaz what happened
I've had friends for I've known for a
year go bad on me 40 years meaning 40
why would he do
that whatever yeah that's I mean that's
in the news right now so that's weird
though what he's got an ax to grind why
they had to pay him to say that though
I'm sure do that like I I'm skeptical of
that
[__]
why you going public well you know he's
a bad person if he's going to go on an
interview he's been Will's friend for 40
years and he knows this is like the Hot
Topic so I don't put too much weight
into it this just a guy looking for
clicks you ever heard this guy before I
haven't no also like I wouldn't do it
anyway Scientology I just wouldn't do it
anyway though that's true Scientology
too once you're out they go for you man
I don't think he was ever in Scientology
Will
Smith I don't think he was I don't think
he oh boy you got to go down that rabbit
but also I just think like what are you
doing dude like what are you doing over
here if you were his friend for 20 years
now you're going bad on him what is it
jealousy fresh printer elron hubard yeah
I don't buy I don't I don't buy it I
think this guy like now that picture
they do look like they busting each
other's butts there I
agree to be fair you and I have had
taken some very gay looking gay dude hey
dude do you remember when we went this
will never ever happen again in the
history of man kind when we went to the
spikes guy Choice Awards sure it was
just guys and they sat us next to Lamar
and you go who's that little fella I
went that's the most famous rapper on
the planet you stupid [__] remember that
I was like he's really like that guy I'm
like he's people were making a fuss I go
who's that little guy my people you mean
me you go that's the best rapper in the
world
Brian yeah guy Choice only it was a guy
Choice only Awards I look really good
they had [__] dance on tables it was
all dudes we fist bumping and cancel
cult well look at how you you just kind
of hang in
here We're Cute there couple Cutie Pies
now we look like we just busting each
other's yeah dare I say dare I say we're
a couple handsome son [__] though
dare I say Brian Ken back then was all
right with with with good hair oh dude
we had views for days dark bar what we
had views for days views for [__]
days and you grow a little older and
they jump off the train jump off the TR
and that mustache sure [__] ain't
helping it ain't helping things right
now no but we're still out it Brandon
we're we're still out it buddy boy a
little grayer a a little more defeated
my Louis Vuitton boots we're coming back
a little wi that cool suit that was in
Santa Monica the GU Choice Awards yeah
those ain't coming back anytime soon no
no they're not God why were we there
couple of I Rob rle we're were waiting
for the truck yeah waiting to get picked
up we're talking with Rob rigle oh
remember remember alucino M MIT was
there too yep it was alucino and um
who's who's the other guy oh uh my
cousin
Vinnie Joes Joe PES was there I [__]
remember that remember he his speech was
so long yeah and was so boring I
remember that but it wasn't live so they
were able to edit it so you don't see on
TV but I was like holy [__] he's not all
there he was like out to launch man he
had a hat on I knew the head of Spike
back then too she was a a woman it was a
woman yeah she's putting out male lonely
content it's a good show good uh good
Spike was that's where I got my start on
Spike yeah they just couldn't make money
what it was a great idea it was all guys
yeah and then they lost Ultimate Fighter
which is their biggest show they lost
cops yep they lost [__] uh wasn't um
Dog the Bounty Hunter on there dude just
all slappers bro cops Dog the Bounty
Hunter and tough yeah those three go
away you're nothing trouble slim jim
pulls out yeah it wasn't the man show on
Spike yes it was dud or was it comy
central no it was on Spike and they had
gals jumping on trampoline tits the the
jugs they they call them juggies isn't
that crazy remember the Juggy [__]
yeah they're just girls with big titties
jumping on trampolines and getting wet
look at that night you could never do
those shows today no yeah so it it was
Comedy Central well the man show was
Comedy Central yeah Cora Jimmy Kimmel
Rogan was on there Doug Stan hope yep
but I think Rogan and Doug Stan hope
they were on Spike
right uh
yeah Spike was and Stan hope were both
that was when ran was dude you open
dudee you open yourself up a six-pack of
straight Bud wiser not the Bud Light gay
stuff I'm talking about the heavy Bud
Light you have yourself a real [__]
100% beef hot dog you watch Fast and
Furious cops Dog the Bounty Hunter The
Man Show fall asleep to The Ultimate
Fighter with your boy on That's right
buddy what a great programming event
100% those days are gone departure of
Kimmel and Corolla they were
great he had some good people on there
yeah any other CR
events any update on that guy who killed
his wife the anything oh I didn't see
anything no they won't give you updates
yet that's an ongoing investig she's
going to court that's all we know yeah
did they they have they identified the
bodies of the grandparents don't poke
the bear saw we saw the pictures don't
poke the
bear oh this one yeah hold on this is a
uh big boy Junior in high school
offensive lineman oh my God if he was in
the NB or the NFL today he would be the
biggest player in the NFL what he's in
high school offensive lineman would be
the biggest player in the NFL but he's
only a junior in high school he's slow
though 9 400 lb and he will squash you
like a bow it is highly recommended that
you don't poke the bear because he will
Unleash the Beast on you his name is
Byron Washington and he wants all the
smoke and he knew he was playing against
the best defensive line in the country
so he had something to prove theodo
hadn't beat Duncanville in over 6 years
so he played with a chip on his shoulder
he let Duncanville know that theodo runs
this
city and his running backs always show
him love because they know he's a cheat
cache the price is going up right now
he's unranked but he should be a five
star no he's too slow will play it in
the NFL one day no no he's too I
guarantee you he doesn't he's too big
and slow ass who's the guy making the
video and I guarantee you he plays in
the NFL he's not ranked right now two
star he's not ranked in the top he's not
even a five star Allstar most of those
five star Allstars don't make it to the
NFL this guy's not even ranked he's too
slow too big and slow tits big tits he
can lose pounds he's a Juggy dude he can
lose weight he's yeah he's too big too
SL yeah if if they're big have good foot
he looks so slow out there and he's not
not even ranked what are we doing so
here's another older video older is
video but uh this looked really cool and
I don't know the all the details of it
but this is obious obviously like a
Russian fighting organization but I'll
show you the
clip this is Russ he can get his ass
right back up he broke his nose check
out his opponent though so
[Applause]
little so that's pretty much the clip
but you know the guy that just literally
just knocked him pretty much out almost
and then helped him the entire time
afterwards what's up BR a terrible clip
right what are you serious hit him and
then was like you all right man
he knew that he was going to be out like
he don't to mess him up anymore what do
you want blood what do you want just do
a victory dance over his body he took a
knee so he you want first it's my
mustache and then it's this [__]
worst podcast ever brenon you're
terrible man [__] a beautiful clip
get the dge I didn't even drink my
[__] magic mine you didn't too much
coffee this morning I'm getting into
this [__] too now man let's go guys
let's go you guys want to get deep
that's it and I want to end this with
some mental Clarity some [__] focused
we keep on going you guys only see about
two hours of our chaotic life [__] yeah
man I got a lot of [__] to do like man
we got to put out a lot of fires [__]
yeah has to touch a lot of kids got to
make a lot of oh well I got to I got to
look like that but you know either way I
look like I cut sandwiches in the deli
or I should good good good Gary I'll see
you this we're almost sold out I'll see
you this weekend and I'm at the ice
house tomorrow night Thursday night Ice
House shopping friends got some monsters
on there my boy LS is coming down from
Phoenix uh and I'm at I'm in Chicago
December 8th and 9th Nashville January
25th atin that's one night only in
Nashville on the 25th and Austin's the
26th through the 27th we got a bunch of
other dates on there thick boy yeah
thick
boy.com uh new episode of Toontown just
dropped with my TRX turn to the demon
get you some it's on you can watch the
full thing on Facebook Twitter Youtube
all new Channel all new show go get you
some all right kids that's right kids
Yak yo I'll see you this Thursday Friday
Saturday that's tomorrow uh Friday
Saturday I can't wait and then Helium
Comedy Club in Indianapolis December 7 8
and9 then we got spaan Comedy Club
Friday December 15th 16 17th God bless
all right kids love you we're out